elle manage bonjour acte 63 donc des
gilets jaune et gilet jaune sont ils au
rendez vous quelle est l'ambiance sur
place
écoutez vous l'entendez peut-être
olivier à l'ambiance elle est plutôt
festive et bon enfant les jeunes et je
vous donne de la voix pour se
fait soixante troisième acte était chez
les jeunes
de passer la carte du dehors et on est
actuellement
[Musique]
les jeunes à cette rumeur
et si les jeunes bien
les slogans hostiles à m
et bien démontré au sens du rythme du
référendum ont certes citoyenneté le
retrait total de la réforme des
retraites une réforme qu'ils jugent
injuste et inefficace alors je suis allé
[Musique]
et j'ai déjà
j'ai repris gratuitement vous êtes
heures manifestation a cassé dans tous
les jours notamment pour contenir la
forme ça fait toujours du bien de
marcher ses conseillers surtout pour
ceux qui ont dit qu'ils abaissent
apparemment je suis les prescriptions et
jeu je me mets en forme en marche énorme
trêve de plaisanterie on est constamment
dans le combat on s'est inscrit dans un
combat donc il est important de
participer aux manifestations de pouvoir
un jour échangé avec l'ensemble des
manifestants et essayer de faire évoluer
un petit peu ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
est d'avoir d'autres avis donc les liens
pourront être présents moi ça me motive
et je pense que ça vous dit aussi pas
mal de gens qu'on soit présent aux
manifestations
c'est évident ça motive mais c'est pas
fatiguant manifesté pour le 63e salon
dès maintenant vous n'avez pas
l'impression que ça mène à rien non pas
forcément ça amène les gens à discuter à
débattre a surtout proposé et il se
permet de se faire entendre du
gouvernement aujourd'hui qui est
carrément sous un à ce qu'on peut
proposer un débat donc on continue
pourquoi être se rendre visible et
espérait avoir un jour quelque chose une
politique ou plus humaine au service des
travailleurs et et qu'on puisse profiter
aujourd'hui de la vie aussi en tant qu'
en tant que français en tant que
travaillant en tant que citoyen tout
simplement à une manifestation qui se
déroule bien depuis ce matin c'est
assez rare pour le souligner bah juillet
ongles justement c'est ça qui est
plaisant c'est que généralement quand ça
se passe bien il n'y a pas de raison que
ça il ya un climat de violence les
policiers sont pas trop oppressant on
reste dans cette nurserie aujourd'hui
d'être accompagné comme des bébés par
des policiers de tous les côtés chose
qui est quand même assez désagréable
mais quand ils sont assez cool et pas
dans un climat de violence ça devrait
bien se passer et espérons le il reste
toujours la prendre manif qui est
toujours les plus difficiles pour
pouvoir sortir ne pas se faire masser et
de coût et de prospection du gaz et donc
on va attendre la fin mais je pense que
ça devrait bien se passer
m gerard piqué ce sujet de la dernière
sortie dvd le maquereau alors à son hôte
aura 2 de son déplacement à d'israël
dans un avis oui là attendez quelques
mois à des journalistes ce qu'ils
dénoncent
un discours bien laisserait entendre
vive la bulle n'est qu'une dictature se
seraient installés en france il a
répondu essayé à la dictature et que
vous verrez qu est-ce que vous avez
alors je sais pas sur laon dictature
mais en tout cas on en prend le chemin
aujourd'hui on subit la répression moi
que ça n'existe pas en dictature ont
subi la mutilation je crois que ça
n'existant qu'en candidature il ya dans
la manifestation un monsieur qui a perdu
un oeil
mais sous l'ère pinochet parce qu'il a
combattu pinochet il a perdu un oeil
c'était une dictature je suis mutilé
d'un oeil pour moi en tout cas on prend
le schéma la dictature
on est jeune on est à mon avis personnel
constamment contrôle d'identité les
policiers nous suivent
enfin c'est du grand n'importe quoi on
est arrêté arbitrairement beaucoup de
gens font de la prison et lui s'en tire
bien et si on reprend la définition du
mot dictature c'est un groupe ou une
personne qui est lui seul décisionnaire
de ce qui va se passer dans l'absolu il
a écouté le peuple
non ici écouté lui même ses petits
copains les plus riches et continue son
programme politique aujourd'hui un
programme je le répète de terreur de par
le sang en utilisant aujourd'hui une
muraille qui s'appelle la police pour
maltraiter le club et joe accomplir son
destin politique au service des plus
riches
merci à jérôme et jerez d'avoir répondu
à nos questions vous l'avez entendu
jérôme rodriguez qui est bien elle se
dit toujours aussi mois
yves est déterminé à poursuivre la
mobilisation était chez les jaunes donc
pour une pause du pouvoir d'achat mais
également pour aérien demandé le retrait
de la réforme des retraites
merci beaucoup et mme nadège nadège
abderzak qui nous fait vivre donc grand
direct de cette manifestation des gilets
jaunes